this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app everyone
I know switched to the cash app and it's
the number one finance in the App
Store's finance app in the App Store so
why have you not switched yet if you
haven't do it they've introduced the
cash card it's a new black debit card
that you can design yourself via the app
allowing you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want plus
it's the best way to pay people back
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android 37 babies I'm gonna be 38 this
year that's weird to me and my back
hurts and every time I wake up it looks
like I didn't sleep and that's just how
it's gonna be from now on I'm old baby
got grazing my beard and the great thing
about social media is everyone keeps
reminding you can't do anything nowadays
without everybody seeing you I'm getting
old and as a guy it's cool to get old
you know you become that George Clooney
Jack Palance nobody knows who he is now
at this point because everybody's 12 but
you become that cool old guy Clint
Eastwood Charles Bronson you know and
it's it's cool I'm linked by the way to
be straight up with you guys I think I'm
gonna be one of those guys I think I'm
gonna look better as I get older I think
I'm lucky I got a long body so the
weight off even out over the [ __ ]
[ __ ] you know what I mean I'm a tall
drink of water it'll [ __ ] even out so
I think it's gonna be okay I don't think
I'll lose too much hair now granted
every time I wash my hair I do this
there's hair
there's hair my hands
looks like I got in a fight a pro
wrestling fight and so but yeah I don't
know but I what I do every time I've if
I sleep for Allah a long time the more I
said the longer I sleep the more it
looks like I did I haven't slept like is
I'm so puffy and [ __ ] and people are
like you look tired and it's like
because I'm still sleeping
so yeah episode 50 right I'm 50 remember
that [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] was so funny
Shanna wasn't in motion I should
definitely know her name because I did a
movie that's coming out with her in
February called half magic but she that
[ __ ] might be the funniest woman I've
ever seen
I mean her [ __ ] is hilarious what she
would do Mary look up Mary Katherine
Gallagher and then look up I don't know
what she did was she dime fifty I don't
know what that that character was called
but she would kick and she be like and I
kick for no reason dude she's so funny
[ __ ] [ __ ] she's so funny Sally
O'Malley SS stupid the name you know she
might be the funniest woman ever but so
anyway hmm let's see it's the first week
how by the way I I was going to the I've
been going to the gym and I kept
expecting people to [ __ ] start the
gyms been dead I don't know what the new
year's resolution was do you go to a gym
they they're there it's dead nobody's
get everyone gave up that's not the new
year's resolution anymore how about that
everyone was like hey thank God 2017 is
over turn a fresh new page hey guys
sorry I have a lot of mucus I don't know
what the [ __ ] going on
it's gross um it's glad the microphone
and fart can amplify that but yeah we
turn the page and then and then Logan
Paul was like hey done let me film a
dead guy and put it on YouTube and
people were like oh it's still 2017 like
[ __ ] I you know this resolution [ __ ]
and like to have the way like the clocks
gonna strike midnight and everything is
gonna go away it's not going to go away
we're [ __ ]
and we're headed
a we're headed downward and it's and
we're Kareem and bro
you ever you ever use that word you
reuse that word careening cuz that's
what we're doing dude we're [ __ ]
Kareem in bro you know you want to live
in a [ __ ] happy place
stop Kareem and dude you know what you
are you're the [ __ ] end of that movie
life with with Jake Gyllenhaal and
[ __ ] Ryan Reynolds and and and you
and where Jake Gyllenhaal [ __ ]
branches off and the girl girl in the
movie who's the girl and we all actually
don't know who she is she's like some
chick I love how like they'll be like
yeah they'll be like yeah we'll get two
big movie stars and then well we got it
just some chick it doesn't matter and
it's some chick that was in like a
British movie or a series on the BBC but
at the ending scene and in life when
when he's like I'm gonna go out in two
we got two pots I'm gonna shoot mine
into outer space and we're gonna shoot
you down to earth and and and this is
the 2017 we think we're in the [ __ ]
the girls pod Carine him back down to
earth
gonna be safe and Jake Gyllenhaal's got
the alien and he's and we think that we
think that we're I don't know if this
analogy works but he's careening into
the [ __ ] outer space and he's gonna
die he's got the alien with him and he's
going out and he's out he's out he's out
and and we're like goodbye [ __ ] in 2017
that's what we think 2017 is that's what
we think yeah and we're like goodbye
2017 you got Jake Gyllenhaal in that
[ __ ] pod with the alien and he's
taking it and he's taking it and he's
[ __ ] he's [ __ ] raining out into
the [ __ ] outer space dude and and
we're like [ __ ] yeah and we think we're
in the pod in 2018 and we're the chick
and we're like yeah we're going back
down to earth we're going back down to
earth and then sure enough when the pod
lands and it opens up guess who's in
earth
and guess who's on earth Jake Gyllenhaal
with the [ __ ] alien dude we thought
the whole time that he was [ __ ]
leaning out into outer space saving the
world
but now the alien the killer [ __ ]
alien that's made of a may made up of
equal muscle and equal brain is on earth
and there will be no sequel because
nobody saw that [ __ ] movie however
that's what we are we thought we were on
the [ __ ] ship up on the safe ship
with the chick we don't have the chick
with us we got Jake Gyllenhaal miss
strong alien with great brain power that
clock struck midnight pada ping we got
the [ __ ] alien with us and Logan Paul
showed us that's the alien Logan Paul
was in the [ __ ] thing Logan Paul was
in the thing we're like we gotta take
[ __ ] Logan Paul with us we got to
take him and we were the hero [ __ ] yeah
we took you know all the [ __ ] going on
in the government everything all the
[ __ ] fires in LA we're out we're
going to [ __ ] in 2018 so take it with
you [ __ ] and then we [ __ ]
crash down to earth and bam the
Taiwanese [ __ ] open up the
thing and Logan Paul's like comes out
what's up YouTube we thought we took him
bro now Cerrone in the end it's a cool
movie you should see it anyway but ruin
the end don't care it's okay to ruin the
end of movies if they've been out for
two years I think I don't give a [ __ ]
also who cares I don't care if someone
runs an end of a movie I don't care I'll
still see the movie or not see the movie
there's still a whole movie that you can
see you don't watch a movie for the
ending I don't like when people say that
oh don't ruin the end you watch the
movie to watch the whole movie you could
if you watch the movie cuz of the
[ __ ] end you're a jackass you're a
jackass if you thought the best part of
M night Shyamalan movies were the end
you're a [ __ ] jackass you're a jackass
the whole movie was good or not good
because then
Shyamalan either makes fantastic movies
or movies that are just me by the way
those are my favorite filmmakers the
ones that [ __ ] make the best movies
and then also just [ __ ] they were
like well I tried something and it
didn't work that's my that's my those
are my favorites
so props M night Shyamalan but yeah
so everyone thought it was gonna be 2018
but it's till 2017 or whatever the [ __ ]
when Logan Paul started the year off by
filming a Japanese uh hey by filming a
corpse and uploading it on YouTube for
literally seven year olds dude like I
don't I I I don't know if I've ever said
publicly something's not funny because
it's subjective and I don't like that I
don't like I don't like when people are
like that's not funny like you can say
like say you don't like say you don't
like a comedian you you can say you
don't think it's funny but you can't say
because they they're not good right like
if they draw crowds I was think that
like if you think take any comedian
[ __ ] whoever Lucy Kay and you're like
yeah he's not good it's like the [ __ ]
out of here he's definitely good at what
he does you don't get to say that he's
not your cup of tea okay cool but I
would watch the I mean I wouldn't watch
I would catch because he's so big some
of the Logan Paul stuff and it's just
and I was like this is [ __ ] shitty you
know what I mean it's just like it's
just like it's for dumb people you know
like like legitimately it's for dumb
people or people who are seven which
you're dumb when you're seven because
you didn't develop yet and you grow up
and hopefully you think that kind of
humor is [ __ ] idiotic or you just
remain dumb as [ __ ] I mean if you're
[ __ ] 30 and you think Logan Paul is
funny you're a [ __ ] idiot straight up
say yeah see ya and so the reason why
I'm talking about it now is because he
[ __ ] was a piece of [ __ ] and I've
actually thought about this so much that
he's he filmed he went into a forest
filmed a [ __ ] guy who recently hung
himself and then uploaded it edited to
edited it [ __ ] put sound effects put
squeaky toy noises over his swear words
by the way
well can't believe we saw dead guy whoa
can't believe we came on boy a guy and
we saw bullying on my own dead guy
you're saying [ __ ] and also it
doesn't matter blurring it doesn't
matter it [ __ ] squeaky toying the
[ __ ] swear word when you're showing a
dead guy to a seven-year-old say yeah
cut your hair take off the hat um but I
I mean I would watch the [ __ ] about Jake
Paul the brother and I was like oh this
guy what the [ __ ] is he doing he's just
being annoying he's like Tom they're
like Tom Green without being funny and
and I was like this guy's just annoying
people and then not at four-year-olds
are like [ __ ] yeah yeah I do poopy I
love him I love him and I do poopy mark
have another cookie yeah a what's my
dear poopy aye but also hey I like to
watch the Logan power that's his fan
base and and I never thought I'd like it
and then I then his Logan Park kid did
some [ __ ] did that I was like oh wow
okay and this was this was like everyone
who thought he was annoying now is like
has ammo and is like oh well he's a
piece of [ __ ]
and I was like I was fascinated by it
because it's it's you know it's it's his
fault but also it's it's everyone who
[ __ ] subscribes to his channels fault
and and watches it and thinks it's good
it's their fault too but it's it's not
their fault as much as it is his fault
and I
and I love I put some [ __ ] on Instagram
that was like this is [ __ ] like how
stupid it was like that that he did this
[ __ ] and like a lot of his fans were
like he apologize get over it I [ __ ]
can't stand here's the thing man we get
to feel bad about that for quite some
time before we get to a stop feeling bad
about it and stop making fun of it you
don't get to dictate how long I get to
feel upset about somebody filming a dead
body and putting it on YouTube and to be
like oh your poor apologize oh cool I'm
fine cool what's he gonna do next then
people are like I'm crying I'm crying
because he didn't put it but you didn't
have a blog out yeah you know why you
crying cause you baby you're a literal
[ __ ] five-year-old that's why he
crying
cuz you're not 30 cuz nobody 30 thinks
he's funny and did you see the other
Japanese [ __ ] that he did in Japan
besides the fact that he went into that
forest and saw the [ __ ] I saw the dead
guy and then put it on YouTube I mean
Jesus Christ dude if he did that if my
[ __ ] family member hung himself and
then he put that [ __ ] on YouTube you
know what I'm doing showing up at his
[ __ ] family house family's house and
doing high kicks that's it that's how
I'm fighting this whole family with high
kicks until I'm exhausted dude and and
and and I I mean these these kids with
our kids or adults they're not funny
dude
they're also there there's no talent
there's no talent it's a guy who sees
who's who's who's praying off reactions
you know it's it's
it's taking the wrong thing from your
successor like Tom Green went out there
and was funny and was the was the object
of the joke Allah everyone was looking
at Tom green thinking like what is this
weirdo doing he's making he's a [ __ ]
weird guy what is he crazy
but Logan Paul and these kids go out and
[ __ ] [ __ ] with people and are racist
and our place is shed and it's taken the
wrong it's it's taken the wrong thing
and and and and and we don't and people
don't know any better
well those people don't know you but if
it's five mm-hmm and it's it's giving a
the Internet has given people with no
talent a platform and the dumb [ __ ]
morons follow this [ __ ] because they
don't know any better because we're all
[ __ ] following everything literally
we're followers that's why Instagram is
so big because because we are following
people on Instagram and that's what we
were doing in real life except the
internet has [ __ ] exposed all of that
[ __ ] and so now these [ __ ] idiots
literally put on Pokemon outfits because
it's something to see it's something to
see it's a visual thing and you're a
[ __ ] CUDA if you're doing this [ __ ]
you're following it because you see a
bright object and you're like oh okay
subscribe eat CUDA I mean he takes his
pants down in the middle of [ __ ] the
street that's not funny
it's just something that's not talent I
mean this this [ __ ] vine app and and
the [ __ ] I mean vine literally ruined
comedy on the Internet
the internet ruin can't ruin ruin a
bunch of comedy I mean not all of it you
still get good [ __ ] you get you know
it's like but it's like goddamn and I
know I I was big on vine and [ __ ] but I
stopped doing it because all these
[ __ ] idiots were like no I'm going
I'm going
don't make a [ __ ] video where
something goes like this don't mean you
[ __ ] [ __ ] who are you trying to
appeal to a [ __ ] six-year-old that's
fine if you're trying to appeal to a
six-year-old if you're a four year old
okay if you're trying
appeal to a six-year-old and your 20 get
captured turn around
why's your nose facing my nose have it
face the same way mine noses facing take
two steps in front of me
let me shimmy behind you and Thuc you
not because I want to but because I know
you don't want me to it's what you
deserve it's so backwards dude so now I
got to the gym and the TMZ guy came up
to me on a skateboard of course I mean
Jesus Christ hey if you're gonna TMZ
somebody don't be on a goddamn
skateboard he's like sup dude like it's
so [ __ ] what do you think Logan Paul
Chris and I was like I didn't even do a
joke I was like bro he's [ __ ]
terrible dingy he's terrible he's a god
really what else and I was like he's
just not funny and now everyone knows it
[ __ ] man
I've been fascinated with this [ __ ]
thing for since it happened a week or
whatever and then he apologized which is
like he's apologizing because and now
he's got more subscribers you [ __ ]
idiots who follow him you 17 million
idiots you 17 million idiots
and guess what there's more than 17
million idiots out there it's just like
God uh so I thought about it I've been
thinking about it all that because it is
so sad for the [ __ ] person's family
it makes me angry because here's the
thing that makes me angry I'm a comedian
that's my [ __ ] profession I work so
hard on coming up with what I think is
funny working it on stage every single
night touring you know and I did it for
no money for years zero money and then I
started making a little money and it's
something I'm very proud of being a
comedian I always wanted to be a
comedian and it's something I'm really
proud of I love that I do it and it's
and you know what it's [ __ ] hard it's
hard it's really hard to do and the fact
that that's comedy and also people will
call like people like that a comedian is
just like and they just willy-nilly and
don't work you know hard I mean you know
look they they've travel and they go to
[ __ ] places and they come up with
vlogs and they edit it and that's work
sure but it's not it's not hard what
they're doing it's not hard and it
doesn't have to be hard to be good
something doesn't have to be hard to be
good but like you're just like I don't
know I I went in to look up like the kid
the guy - not same kid he's [ __ ] 22
and I looked up the like what is this
kid come from guy come from and I found
his dad on Instagram and that [ __ ]
talking about at the end of a movie that
was like I was like
now I get it
his dad says numchucks oh so now I get
it I saw a video of his dad with
nunchucks and he said man I used to be
good with numbers like yeah and then
said numchucks again it wasn't a mistake
oh that's how you end up getting adult
as a child jesus [ __ ] christ man I
watched a lot of his dad's videos and
his dad's older than me and like he's
just doing what [ __ ] his son does
he's like what's up guys yeah like what
hey man what the [ __ ] is happening
what on God's [ __ ] green and brown
earth is [ __ ] happening I'm looking
at a video right now of his dad in a
[ __ ] bunny outfit hey man you FIF hey
man you got five decades behind you you
v she doing writing notes on paper and
showing it to [ __ ] Instagram happy
fourth [ __ ] it happy fourth 350,000
thank you new vlog Lincoln bio your
fifth dude are you Mary O'Malley or
whatever the [ __ ] malli O'Malley what
the [ __ ] was it Sally O'Malley Hey Dude
are you Sally O'Malley cuz you're 50
what are you doing having a vlog numb
dude you got to watch this nunchuck
video this guy did Logan Paul's dad
first of all it's a [ __ ] it's sin
secure its sin see dude are you from
[ __ ] Cincinnati and guess what they
live in Ohio yes
see dude I so [ __ ] now he's flipping
the [ __ ] thing I'll hurt himself hurt
himself hit his back hurt himself so
[ __ ]
Cinci dude his face is he's just like
[ __ ] since he and he's like oh dude
who does not nunchucks has ever been a
[ __ ] guy who didn't unchecks that
didn't look sensei unless unless you
know you're like [ __ ] it your whole
life but like don't be [ __ ] god
here's the thing that like what do we do
today that's that's the thing that's the
thing that [ __ ] up comedy on the
internet what do we do today guys what
are we gonna do today I don't know let's
get some peanut butter rub it all over
our [ __ ] face and [ __ ] cool want to
film it great you're not a writers room
you know you're a [ __ ] 17 year old in
your mom's house what we're doing today
guys did i watch this [ __ ] guy i
watched this guy the dad and in in inva
and in the thing and i went way down
because I want to see way down on his
Instagram and he was like just working
on some vines oh my god working on some
buds and he had a [ __ ] wig on yeah
[Applause]
dude you got bags under your eyes Oh God
God vine [ __ ] ruined it man and then
they're giving me all these vine guys
opportunities it's so funny too because
like the kids are like just following
them blindly and then vine and then and
then like the corporation's will be like
oh well they're popular we got to give
them a [ __ ] shot and then they'll do
like a commercial with like you know
Kleenex and it'll be some [ __ ] and
like you know
some vine guy will be like doing the
commercial and it'll be [ __ ]
piss-poor because all the other guys in
it now this is real life hey you entered
real life now like this is what happened
like now real life knows about logan
paul after the hanging incident now real
life knows about you and real life
thinks that that [ __ ] is [ __ ] and you
don't and now you're like oh so these
corporations will give these guys money
to do these videos on Instagram or
whatever the [ __ ] and you're playing
yourself dude you Jenner the damage up
because you playing yourself put on
Giroud the damages funky-ass kung fu
outfit cuz you playing yourself and no
and people and it's not it doesn't work
and now you're seeing the [ __ ] and
you're like oh what's that [ __ ]
stupid ad and it's like because they're
these [ __ ] 50 year old dudes who have
a corporation or like let's just go with
what the van guy says and now again turd
the real world and it doesn't work but
it's not getting better
we're careening baby and we think 2018
is gonna be better and the positive
people think mm 2019 is gonna be better
and the positive people think 2020 is
gonna be better but guess what there's
not even gonna be a 2021 because we're
in that [ __ ] spaceship at the end of
life the movie and we've got the alien
Logan Paul in that [ __ ] pod we're
[ __ ]
but we're not going to
you know the good thing is that the
[ __ ] guys are still out there that
are talented doing [ __ ]
but the talented people are never gonna
be the people who are on top I mean very
rarely right know your lanes stay in it
and I don't know I don't even know if
that's good if I stay in your [ __ ]
lane but enough on that square cache hmm
everybody all the babies and everybody I
know has switched to cash the cash up
it's the number one finance app in the
App Store
maybe because it's the best way to pay
people back do you ever think that
friends you could pay people back
friends family co-workers enemies Logan
Paul setting and receiving money is
totally free and fast and most payments
can be deposited directly into your bank
account in seconds all right Square cash
is better if I like it better than the
other guys because the other apps
because you it doesn't list your stuff
in a feed and you don't have to people
don't see if you're paying somebody back
for like supplies or whatever art
supplies I don't know people know what
I'm an artist I'm a down time getting
paint and stuff there's a new cash card
it's a black debit card that you can
design yourself via the app the cash
card allows you to use the cash that you
keep in the app anywhere you want you
get notifications for all payment made
with the card directly via the cash app
and you can laser-etched your card to
personalize it and will be delivered
directly to you for free the cash app
team is constantly building awesome new
features so what are you do using the
other they'll use the other apps get the
cash app today
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android now cool back
still hurts got to get a different chair
this chair is just like I was this chair
for this is like the [ __ ] hurt
yourself chair so like I was thinking
about to this this thing in the in the
world I think that there's mm-hmm I
haven't really thought this out well
very well so [ __ ] take a journey with
me you guys are you a baby are you a
true baby take a journey through take a
journey through take a journey with me I
don't know how to say that get on board
get on this [ __ ] low little boat
start we're gonna start paddling okay I
was telling something to a friend and
they didn't really feel what I was
saying and what I was telling them was a
story I'm not gonna tell the story cuz
it doesn't matter but it wasn't an him
it was a like an emotional kind of
sentimental story that's the word right
and they were like so here's the thing
my let me just tell this story because
not this one but then another one my
buddy was telling me once that he worked
at an Italian restaurant and he in the
beginning of working at the Italian
restaurant needed a pen and one of the
Busboys gave him a pen to use for his
[ __ ] and he kept that pen and used that
pen the whole time while he was working
there and on his last day the job he
went up to that other busboy and said
hey or no you know what it was actually
a different [ __ ] pen he gave him a
pen when he first did the thing he
didn't keep the pen and then later on
when he was when he when he left the job
he said hey man when you were when you
when I was first here I needed a pen
and you gave me a pen and I know it's
nothing but you help me out in a small
way and I just wanted to give you this
pen because I was uh I was I'm leaving
and just like I don't know like you're
staying here and I [ __ ] wanted to
give you this pen because you gave me a
pad and you helped me whatever it was a
cute thing and it's sentimental I guess
and I don't know if somebody did that to
me
I would be like oh that's sweet I would
be like that's that's very uh that's
thoughtful and you know it's silly but
it's it's sweet and my buddy who had
that story happen to him was telling his
other buddy that story and the other guy
was like the [ __ ] are you talking about
it's just a pen and he was like I don't
get it you know and he didn't get it he
was like that's stupid he just gave you
a pen and he didn't feel that sentiment
and I think that like there are that's
it like distinct difference between two
people two types of people like you
either feel that or you don't and if you
don't feel that then I think your
emotional intelligence is I think
emotional intelligence is in a lot of
ways more beneficial than like was it EQ
they talked about have you heard about
this EQ with an IQ like in in in my
world EQ is more important because I do
stand-up and I have a bunch of friends
and [ __ ] like that that do this debtor
of like that did do that you know I
don't have any [ __ ] scientist friends
I'm sure like if you work in a
laboratory you need a your [ __ ] high
IQ but it's like and maybe they don't
have like a high EQ but like you need to
have that to be I think in my life and I
have plenty of friends that aren't like
that
that don't get sentimental [ __ ] like
that and think it's stupid but I feel
like I can't be very close to those
kinds of people and it's not like a
conscious thing I'm doing but I just
feel like it's a shame that I can't
connect with them in that way
and I don't know I was just thinking
about that and thinking about how and I
was wondering who like other people were
who like that is like people like I like
what is Donald Trump like that like I
want to know if like people are like
that like it's the rock like that is I
think a rock is like that cuz they
Instagram videos he posts or a really
sweet and sentimental but then there are
people who do [ __ ] like that because
they think other people do [ __ ] like
that and they're Psychopaths and like
I'm listening to this podcast called
dirty Jon and it's about a [ __ ]
textbook psychopath that like romances
women and like swindles them and tries
to take their money and then like
blackmails lamb and [ __ ] so it's like
[ __ ] I'm I sound so high but it's like
sometimes when I'm doing a nice thing
for somebody I start thinking like yeah
but am I doing this because I want to do
this or am I doing this because I think
that this is the right thing to do now I
guess it doesn't matter but then there's
the other thing where it's like I'm
doing this because it's what somebody
who is a good guy will do and here's the
worst thing to do I'm doing this because
I think it's scoring me points with God
I guess it doesn't matter as long as
you're doing good things but also it
does matter because if you're doing
something nice because you genuinely
want to do it and you want somebody else
to be happy then that's the best but if
you're doing something nice because
you're like I want to get into heaven
even though you're doing something nice
is sacred piece of [ __ ] you self-serving
the ice cream you self-serving you know
you know the same you secret piece of
[ __ ] you're trying to get into heaven
you secret piece of [ __ ] let's face
facts the gun because I'm not ever
secretly trying to get into heaven I
know that but I did a thing that a
quote-unquote nice guy would do good guy
would do a week ago and I did it because
I thought it was the right thing to do
but then I started [ __ ] myself up
because I was thinking myself thinking
about it too much because I was like if
you do a nice thing and you brag about
it you know it depending on how you talk
about it like there's this guy on social
media that constantly [ __ ] posts the
good [ __ ] he does and it's like I could
get it you're a role model but also you
know what are you doing this for you're
I think he's bona fide psychopath and
he's just like oh this makes me look
good it's just [ __ ] an interesting
man because like I did a ok so I did a
benefit first cent in Santa Rosa for the
fires and I was talking to Nikki Glaser
because we both did the the [ __ ] the
the benefit and she's comedian she's
hilarious go look her up but but we were
posting this picture we were both in the
picture and we were both gonna post on
Instagram and I was like how do we post
this picture without like I wanted to
bring awareness to the event and say
like oh yeah we raised money for the
poems but the reason why I wanted to do
that was not to look like oh I'm [ __ ]
great because I wanted people to know
that I talk a lot of [ __ ] and I make fun
of a lot of stuff but I wanted people to
know who look I'm in a position where
point-blank some people look up to me
just because of who I am and I'm I mean
I'm I have a lot of followers and [ __ ]
so I wanted people to know that it's
okay to be like that if if for some
reason you admire me I wanted you to
know you you should also have that part
about you and not just be this guy who
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] fashion [ __ ] these
idiots out there who go to the gym and
you know what I mean like I wanted
people to know that oh you should have
that side of you too for the kids for
the [ __ ] kids you know and but I
didn't want to be like look what we did
you know so so I posted about it in a
way where I wasn't I was trying to not
be look what I did
but dude there are so many [ __ ]
comedians out there even that will be
like the whole we change lives thing and
it's like it's just so [ __ ] annoying
dude it's taking the good thing you did
and [ __ ] shoving it right up
somebody's [ __ ] you trying to get
points with god you pace your [ __ ] you
secret piece of [ __ ] you're trying to
get points with God you secret piece of
[ __ ] that's not what Jesus Christ would
do this [ __ ] what would Jesus do
bracelets do it hey man let me buy all
those and wipe my [ __ ] ass with those
I want to store them there you know what
I want to do with those what would Jesus
do bracelets I wanted do you know one do
I want to [ __ ] tie I want to tie a
bunch of them together tie one end to
the back of my hair run it down my back
in between my [ __ ] take the rest take
the end of other end tighter on my balls
and [ __ ] so there's constantly one of
those bracelets in between my [ __ ]
[ __ ] and I want to do this
so it's wiping it tie the back of my
[ __ ] hair with a would Jesus do
bracelet tie them all together trail
them down the [ __ ] small in the back
tie it around my [ __ ] [ __ ] and balls
make sure that the [ __ ] one or two
bracelets is in between my [ __ ] swamp
ass cheeks and then I want to do like
this
and roll around in my bed so I'm
constantly getting [ __ ] on those
bracelets and then I want to rotate them
[ __ ] take the one that got [ __ ] put
it in hand it to a roll holy roller hey
where this what would Jesus do
hey by the way it got [ __ ] all over your
wrist and then [ __ ] rotate them and
then go back to piss pump in both of
them rolling around in my bed getting
rest of them all shitty and then handed
down to a Holy Roller how much would
they be like even if they found that out
holy mother [ __ ] would be like you
know what yeah there was [ __ ] on it but
it doesn't matter because it was for
Jesus anyway and good and it's in secret
life
you just got [ __ ] all over your wrist
that's really all that happened and when
you die you're not going to have you
know why you're not going to have
because you Probab
and also more likely prob does insist I
hope there's a heaven man yeah that'd be
awesome
but here's why I don't think here's
where I think maybe there's not a heaven
because I haven't supposed to be [ __ ]
perfect right you're the afterlife and
you're supposed to [ __ ] live your
[ __ ] and have the best time ever
and all the rules are [ __ ] beautiful
and you get whatever you want because
you were a good guy in the [ __ ] trial
life okay but say I've fallen is half
fall in love with a girl sad love her so
[ __ ] much and then say she breaks my
heart and then say she gets married
again and then she falls in love with
her [ __ ] new guy and saved the rest
of my life I [ __ ] think about her
every day
and I wish she was with me and I'm a
good purse and I [ __ ] do everything I
do for other people not to get points
with God but because I want to be a good
person anyway and more delicious and say
she is too and she falls in love with
another man and loves his [ __ ] out that
guy and she's good purse and she doesn't
want to [ __ ] do things to get points
with God she wants to do things because
she's a good person and then say I die
and I go to heaven what do I want
I want to be with her and then say she
dies and she goes to heaven and what
does she one she wants to be with that
guy still so min hell cuz I can't be
with her
it's how the [ __ ] is there a heaven if
everybody's heaven is different then
what then [ __ ] what I'm in heaven
she's not there or she is there or a
version of her is there but then it's
not the real her then we're getting into
some [ __ ] Blackmer [ __ ] I want the
real her I'm just saying it's something
to think about dude I'm sure there's
some [ __ ] buttoned-up [ __ ]
that can tell me what the hell is going
on however I don't know man
what if my [ __ ] dog do all do dogs
gonna heaven dude and if they do what my
doggy hates me what my dogs like dude I
can't wait to get out this [ __ ] house
I hate this [ __ ] guy all he does is
like to hold me and [ __ ] dog gets to
heaven goes to doggy heaven or does he
go [ __ ] do I still get to own him
come on man doesn't want to be owned you
know how I know I left the door open
once my dog took a [ __ ]
vacation man until somebody picked them
up and called me yeah dude uh so I don't
know I I trailed off here there was some
I wanted to talk about but I don't
remember I don't remember I always I
mean Mormons we're [ __ ] underwear you
know they were [ __ ] holy underwear I
would love for them to die and go to
heaven no I wouldn't want them to die
but I would love for them when they die
go to heaven and be like hey we did
everything in and God was like why do
that stupid [ __ ] underwear that'd be
hilarious good oh we thought that's what
you wanted
oh well it doesn't matter well we we
still made us good people huh God let
God rolls his eyes that's my god
God rolls his [ __ ] eyes that's what I
want when I get to if I if there is one
and I get there I want my God to be like
how about these [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
on earth I don't laugh and we'll both
laugh and [ __ ] man you know we don't
think enough what heaven would be like I
think we're just like oh yeah it'll be
great
it'll be great we don't think about what
the [ __ ] the logistics of it would be
you know Tupac's my favorite is he there
Tupac probably wouldn't even [ __ ]
like me he'll be like did this
[ __ ] get out of my sight yeah
then I'd be like but Jesus I love Tupac
and then Jesus would be like he doesn't
look he thinks you're not funny
he thinks you're lanky and he said that
you he doesn't like your beard and I'd
be like what what the [ __ ] side have to
do with anything is not who I am and he
was like he just didn't get along he
doesn't like you he said he didn't like
your type of person you don't like your
type of people not I'm like well he's
racist no it's not a racist thing you
said you didn't like like guys who you
think you laugh at your jokes too much
well [ __ ] this is hell and he's like
is it really though you got all the
[ __ ] turkey you want and you can get
[ __ ] whenever you want I'm like I
guess yeah I mean but just weird though
it's not really heaven you know it's
just kind of like another kind of I kind
of got as many [ __ ] as I wanted in
my life and I could just go to the store
to Turkey and he'd be like yeah well
what did you [ __ ] want I mean there's
too many people out there you can still
listen it Tupac's music I'm like yeah I
guess I'd be like this is just like
earth you what the [ __ ] and then Jesus
would be like well it's [ __ ] hard up
here beyond these clouds I'm trying to
make everybody happy you know and I a I
didn't you know I didn't think Tupac
wasn't gonna like I wasn't sure and now
I got an o2 park doesn't like because
he's dead and I'm dead too and weren't
that's worse I was imagine Tupac and I
might get along and then Jesus is like
you know [ __ ] look Napoleon was a
good guy yeah he tried to conquer the
world but like in his heart of hearts
even though that means nothing he was a
good guy
even though people say heart of hearts
and that means nothing Napoleon was a
good guy he helped a lot of people and
he's here and he's trying to take over a
lot of heaven and I don't know how to
fix it
I got him some women and he has sex with
a lot of women and it's actually pretty
shitty because I feel like I'm sexist
but at least
not conquering the parts of heaven that
I love because he's getting sucked off a
lot and honestly he gets along with
Tupac and I gotta be like [ __ ]
Napoleon gets along with Tupac he he's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] man
alright whatever I guess at least can I
have sex with Emily right a chat Kowski
and he's like he's like listen that's
she happens to think you look like a
bird and I'm like my mother [ __ ] dude
that's that's heaven that's heaven you
can't have your [ __ ] oh you can't
unless you're gonna have your own heaven
alright now okay oh I can't have sex
with Emily ratted to chow ski I did it
cuz she doesn't want to have sex with me
in heaven just like in [ __ ] earth
probably [ __ ] and then he's like listen
there's some other bad news my god I'm
like what there's like logan paul and
jake paul just got into a car accident
and they're here and I'm like you're
kidding me what the [ __ ] and he's like
well you've been dead for quite some
time and yeah he filmed of hanging
corpse and that was bad and I thought he
was gonna actually go to hell but since
then he's only done good and repented
and I'm like oh no and he's like so he's
here and then faintly in the background
I hear what's up heaven tube and I'm
like there's heaven tube and then he's
like and then he's like for [ __ ] and
then he's like well he that's what he
wanted and I'm like but I don't want
that heaven is just like earth or it's
not or it's not and you just die and you
sleep
forever now [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] myself up
now I dude I used to stay up at night as
a kid and just think of well if you just
die then what happens everything just
stops and I'd get panic attacks and
running to my parents room and be like
mom dad what happens when you die and
they'd be like Chris it's 12:30 we've
been sleeping for six hours go to bed
his parents go to bed all [ __ ] early
and [ __ ] oh man and I go to bed and try
to [ __ ] and I remember I one time I
was going to bed and I had bunk beds
because I was I'm white and my dad's
like what are you even scared of and I
literally said everything Birds that was
like what came to mind
killers Birds I said [ __ ] I would
what a lunatic kid I was man okay here
we go we got a new elder man in instant
elder status for Olivia Mendizabal
Mendizabal Mendizabal aka at City
underscore Liv she runs the
congratulations quotes Twitter we love
this account man it's at quote congrats
it's really funny give it a follow well
I shouldn't say it's really funny
because it's literally just stuff I said
so it's a [ __ ] but it makes me laugh cuz
I don't even remember the [ __ ] I say and
then I see it and then I'm like I said
that [ __ ] and I think what a [ __ ]
idiot I am you know like I [ __ ] him
like I like watch it looking at it
because I think like what a [ __ ]
piece of [ __ ] I said that that's so
stupid I mean some of it I'm like oh
yeah that's funny but some of them like
wow that's not funny what a [ __ ]
idiot I am
which makes me laugh even more will DM
you with the details thanks Olivia
Mendizabal I'm invisible
[ __ ] John Travolta tried to speak
that singer's name Adina Amit's any not
what the [ __ ] did he say
oh [ __ ] his face what's her name at
Deena Menzel or something Adel Nazim
when he said it his face was Shin see
yeah dude when he said it he was from
[ __ ] Cincinnati man
Cincinnati dude ass insecure what'd he
say
adele dazeem so far from it he might
have said he might as well have said
upchuck [ __ ] for breakfast
please welcome upchuck [ __ ] for
breakfast at least everyone would be
like oh [ __ ] damn
Wow he [ __ ] he went out with it he
went out dude I mean that's awesome you
know Wow
upchuck [ __ ] for breakfast you know John
Travolta when he said that in his face
he tried to keep his face smiling
alright let's look at some twit Twitter
questions look about how [ __ ] H&M did
the [ __ ] I can't believe it's a sweet
is it a Swedish based company somewhere
like that you know and with only white
people and they came out with that
[ __ ] hoodie that says coolest monkey
in the jungle and they had a black kid
model it on their catalog dude what by
the way the kid
this is maybe weird that kid is the most
handsome kid I've ever seen in my life
dude I mean the kid is like six or
something and he's [ __ ] like smoke in
the camera dude it looks like he's
thinking what's up [ __ ] but how about
Swedish people and then they give an
apology I was like we regret doing it
we're sorry so Swedish to just be like
that sorry oh how we doing we didn't
mean to we put a kid in there we just
thought that kid was cute we had no idea
about the racial tension and all that
anyway we're gonna make some other
hoodies and it will be fine
there are no guns here nobody kills each
other so we don't really know what it's
like over there but um we're sorry
anyway we're gonna eat some food and
make some more hoodies and call it a day
so we service if we heard anybody um
going to go have sex with the most
beautiful women and it's a beautiful
snowy town and we never had a war here
so we'll catch you later sorry for
hurting a family or two bye
and then [ __ ] Boogie Nights
you know man we just came to a party uh
uh drinking the champagne what are you
celebrating being Swedish yeah
I mean how do you expect them to [ __ ]
no no I mean how much would they be like
what you look like how much would they
be like well he looks like that [ __ ] you
guys don't know what's going on anyway
your your sit your America is in
[ __ ] trouble anyway turn the music
louder ding ding ding ding ding ding
ding ding ding ding I love this one hey
did you want to shock me off yeah do you
know no only if you eat me out
afterwards no name
it'll can be reciprocal [ __ ] in Sark
Ian I love being in Sweden what was what
was I dealing with again an hour ago I
forget play the song again we're still
celebrating celebrating what being
Swedish ah ding ding ding ding ding ding
that ding ding ding ding let's play xbox
one we're being Swedish I can tell what
black people look like like just so
don't give a [ __ ] you know I care about
black people look like hey who wants to
make me [ __ ] this time I'm eating turkey
and [ __ ] getting sock it's so
beautiful outside snowing
we probably all have bad breath how
swedish is it - probably a bad breath no
I actually [ __ ] disagree with that
I bet - [ __ ] Swedish people some I
know probably their armpits some of them
smell bad because they're like [ __ ] the
odorant this is great
our life is amazing [ __ ] this deodorant
but hum but I bet they're for I bet some
Swedish people smell so goddamn good
it's like [ __ ] candy and you need to
have your face in their face male or
female not in a gay way but you want to
be like yo bro let me breathe your
breath
you know I guarantee there's some
Swedish I guarantee the best smelling
[ __ ] breath is Swedish and
you're like yo bro let me smell your
[ __ ] breath get your [ __ ] face
close to mine
breathe in me [ __ ] say something
so I can [ __ ] smell your breath and
he's like I can't help what black people
look like and you smell any like oh [ __ ]
yeah you're racist and you don't know it
but you kind of not racist cuz you're
just saying [ __ ] it's weird you guys are
perfect you got the best lives this is
heaven yeah I think you're right Sweden
is better than heaven everyone seems to
be getting along
I think Tupac would like me here you
ain't half bad in Sweden yeah [ __ ] it
and [ __ ] it you know we don't need to
diss questions or Instagram post of the
week Oh actually I want to do this one
Austin Trudeau
Trudeau at Trudeau underscore train
weird don't call yourself train don't do
that
hey all aboard the Austin train thoughts
on regular ask people that apologize for
not posting on social media for a while
did I've actually talked about the
divorce somewhere probably on Instagram
but dude get the [ __ ] over yourself bro
I'm sorry I haven't been active on a
social media you don't have to apologize
for not doing something
that's like saying sorry I didn't go to
the [ __ ] supermarket today I don't
give a [ __ ] ah dude my condolences Oh my
condolences you didn't [ __ ] post some
[ __ ] post picture of scenery
or a [ __ ] salad on Instagram or a
goddamn selfie I don't give a [ __ ] you
don't have fans your person you work a
Chase Bank uh I'm done fellas we did
over an hour and I'm sweating like a
[ __ ] everybody so hug them again
for that song did it I heard that the
other day subscribe to the YouTube
channel you can watch me man watch me do
this [ __ ] [ __ ] vlogs watch this [ __ ]
[ __ ] vlogs dude you know why [ __ ]
vlogs dude because they cut in there I
don't want to watch a guy who's like in
mid-sentence and you cut his sentence
together what the [ __ ] did he really say
I that's what I always wonder vlogs were
like hey guys it's a great day today
cut went to the market what the [ __ ] did
he say in the middle of it hey guys it's
a great day today killed a homeless guy
then went to the market like what are
you cutting out you [ __ ] with a
with [ __ ] bad hair dude [ __ ] anyone
who made a blogs hair period get a
different haircut and stop cutting out
what the [ __ ] you're saying this [ __ ] is
straight up front to back no editing you
know why dude cuz I'm not you know why
cuz I'm raw which sees what you get and
granted when I become when if I become a
big star it's gonna be so much [ __ ] up
what I said on this it's gonna bite them
in the ass it's gonna take maunder but I
don't give a [ __ ] so when you play these
clips that take me under when I'm doing
[ __ ] big big [ __ ] studio movies
when they're like wish
cut him out of the whole movie because
of what he said about [ __ ] whatever
dogs you know what dude play this clip -
I don't give a [ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
I don't care
you know why dude because no matter what
you do or what you say you don't [ __ ]
you don't know me cuz you don't [ __ ]
know me [ __ ] no matter what the
[ __ ] I'm saying this is a comedy podcast
and I'm trying and I'm trying to explain
how the [ __ ] I am
but you don't know you don't know who I
am you don't know who I am cuz you don't
hang out with me you don't spend time
with me you know - pillow talk you don't
do pillow talk to me I haven't [ __ ]
you and then laid with you for a little
bit I haven't made love to you we
haven't gone out and [ __ ] gun and to
like Best Buy and picked up something I
needed and come back we even sat and
talked about some [ __ ] while we watched
shitty infomercials on TV we haven't
done that [ __ ] so play this clip to my
mind dude alright I'm out
download yo my app bro you got to get my
[ __ ] app that's the thing - subscribe
rate and review the show tweet me by
using the and they handle congrats spot
or by using the hash tag video episodes
go up Tuesday's or Wednesday Wednesday's
upcoming show Pasadena Tampa Winnipeg
Calgary Saskatchewan and I'm starting a
new tour and it's called don't shoot the
messenger but now you can watch my older
stuff man on fire incorrigible white
male black comic you can watch on our
comedy central.com I just retweeted the
link I believe it's free
and thanks for listening and please for
the love of [ __ ] Nicolas Cage
unfollow Logan Paul on any social